[Music]
so more asian women are having sex with
white dudes than asian men
[ __ ] you guys what the hell is going on
right here [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] you steve
dropping the mic dude stealing our women
is this even an article you guys just
have bigger dicks is that the end of the
video that's that's maddie how do you
feel how do you explain all these
chinese people in the world then
they're all halfers
they're not [ __ ] white guys yeah wait
where is this
we're the dominant aryan race that's why
no this is uh a study that was done from
these researchers named david harris and
hirumi ono they found statistical
evidence for what what most already know
intuitively that asian women primarily
of
japanese chinese and korean descent are
having more sex with white men than with
asian it's because they know that
they're not going to marry them so they
want to just [ __ ] get them out of the
way and then marry so you think
absolutely are you sure yeah
would you like to bet money on it you
guys are in for the short con you know
what i mean yeah you're just a ride
that's what you want that's all you are
that's a good [ __ ] decision you guys
just think i'm a ride huh yeah we'll see
about mr right now see about that you
don't got the legs to last brother oh i
brother i've been doing squash recently
dude let's see how many you can do right
now in a row let's see how much you're
gonna discipline your children though
yeah dude why not see how long you can
handle asian women for okay i guarantee
you it's not for a lifetime am i right
brother i've had my chick for 10 years
brother
but the only person here that's with the
asian girl is steve right yeah
hey guess what you could have them dude
anthony oh yeah
well what about anthony
well she's still she's full filipino
she's more pacific this isn't about me
anymore okay let's focus on the white
guy
let's focus on latino
mr nikki limo green okay
fine five against one as usual no
problem hey stop being on cam like
that's not five easy show everybody well
isn't that is it if this room was this
article wouldn't that be true yeah yeah
but yeah that's true yes
because none of us are [ __ ] asian
girls right now that's true i don't i
don't understand that just keep on
saying the same thing
but statistically right yeah i think
just reaction on the fact that when he
[ __ ] an asian person it goes wrong but
like is that is that research being done
in those respective countries
yeah where we're like japanese people in
japan are [ __ ] up probably not [ __ ]
this is probably like in australia or
the uk or whatever like [ __ ]
switzerland yeah they're just like uh
people that we didn't do a poll from uh
china japan and korea
imagine it's in like they'll do the
interview it'll be like this asian
looking woman and they're like which
race do you [ __ ] a lot of white guys
she's like yeah i foxy white guys
it's like what [ __ ] country is that
it's germany all i know is i saw the
title of this one and i just decided to
use it to jump on you guys and that's it
that's cherry picking research man yeah
yeah you wrote this article dude these
are malicious choices i only pick
articles on death he only picks them on
white people having sex with asians god
damn it we're taking over i choose to
take it over
hey tomorrow when i do articles i'll be
like so a white crypto enthusiast was
raped
i'm like again
another one of these yeah great here we
go again
uh
so the sampling included only asian
women born in the united states if and
if the sampling had included only asian
women born in the united states the
number would even be even higher
so they're like don't even make us do
another survey man
like you don't want to know
is that another one of those statistics
you want me to turn this page
isn't that another one of those weird
substitutions like how many like white
men are in
america absolutely it is so stupid but
also uh asian is the most popular
category on pornhub is it really but not
asian men though
depending on the state depending on the
state i thought it was step bros
usually when i go on foreign
white men [ __ ] white
or black man
that's my search hello buddy i gotta
click on these [ __ ] traffic lights yo
if nina catches if nina catches your
[ __ ] browser history it's like white
men that's what you're looking up
vigorous white men i'm like neither
figure i could do that was that you i
don't statistically you're supposed to
get like that who's more likely to dude
anthony's gonna call him and like pick a
fight with nina like oh so i bet you
think that white guy is pretty good
looking huh and steve said
okay steve said that asian women
statistically [ __ ] white men more
ethnicity ebony's number one right now
japanese is number two wow specifically
is this specifically pornhub wait that's
not that's not ranking yeah that's
that's the amount of that one dude
i'm not cooking that one
that says
why is that link a different color
though
why is it purple
oh that's not ranking that's these are
oh most videos i've viewed
my articles being used against me
you might also like
yeah
suggested porn where do you find like
the top [ __ ] no no what i saw
actually
it was a map
and it it told it tells you like the
most popular
search per state oh per state yeah i
want a white man joy that's what i want
i want a white man telling me how to
jerk off you probably could find a lot
of white man jlis
i'd even think about that a white guy
j-o-i yeah that's what i want i want a
white man what kind of what's your
favorite white man thing a white guy
drill sergeant d joi yeah dude just like
real [ __ ] military i think bart quan
doing joi is the best thing
you guys stop salivating for one second
about this white man drill sergeant jay
oh that's good what the [ __ ] is that
that's how you jerk your dick
that's a sorry excuse for a dick you
call that a grip son
oh who's that guy what was on the
the history channel the military guy
remember him arleigh or me from the what
the [ __ ] is that
dude my dick is hard right now thinking
about that i wanted to call me gomer
pyle
yes sir right now sir yeah it doesn't
say metal jacket jli baby oh god
it just says how many [ __ ] videos
apparently there's goddamn million ebony
videos
that's a popular that's a pop
and i'm still gonna
i just like the visual of a white dude
complaining about ebony category
i'm drowning here there's only 7 000 in
german videos like come on guys let's
get the representation up a little bit
what does german porn look like i don't
know it's pretty nine
nine
i mean it just looks like our porn if
they didn't speak yeah dude tell you
your journal
i think i already told you guys an
underrated porn search is chav c-h-a-v
where's that oh no is that bad you know
oh yeah yeah that's like um oh like a
scouser
what the [ __ ]
anthony's like i already didn't know
what the first one was what the [ __ ] is
that you're talking about chavin
right now scouser is like from uh just
outside getting blown is that what java
is
no it's like a style like a thug like
it's like british [ __ ] uh british
it's like jersey shore british yeah
that's pretty funny
because they're always [ __ ] talking
they're always like in the middle of it
they just won't shut up there was a as
the brits say chatting [ __ ]
and [ __ ] welsh
how does this sound do you do you fellas
welsh slag let stranger [ __ ] ask for a
ciggy
that's why i think it's funny man dude
it's [ __ ] like that
yo
yeah she's it's like saying [ __ ] it's
like a slow yeah yeah like
it's like a salute she's a welsh slag
slag sounds like dude whoever [ __ ]
titled that is a good writer yeah
what a hooligan that guy huh you like
you gotta click it and see like i gotta
see what this is kind of funny i gotta
kind of find out what's going on
what's the punch line it's so funny man
i bet they're all really pale huh
or am i wrong it's just british looking
chicks for sure like not a cloud or
they've never seen the sun
they sometimes have like fake tanner
yeah they look oompa loompa yeah i like
that [ __ ] i like all the fake [ __ ] bring
it i like i like
the jersey short chicks with all the
fake [ __ ] going on like fake nails fake
hair fake eyelashes everything what is
it about the pristine walmart look that
makes you go oh yeah just trashy gets my
[ __ ] [ __ ] going so when you're at
fremont street you must be like ooh we
gotta go home now i'm like
steve's like biting his finger like this
yeah i did i mean honestly when nikki
nikki knows like when she wants my
attention she just dresses trashy it's
[ __ ] awesome she looks like pink
bundy yeah yeah exactly no exactly big
money's hot as [ __ ] i don't know how all
guys don't love that because to me i'm
just like yeah give me the peg bundy
thing every time the fact that that guy
was [ __ ] over it was one of the
funniest parts of the show hilarious
yeah it was great
that show is so good it's so good man
hey o'neill so funny katie seagal did it
perfectly yeah she's great yeah she's
awesome she's still hot too yeah yeah
she looks great she's because she's on
like sons of our anarchy what about sons
of anarchy what about the biker look
does that give you i love it i [ __ ]
love it is that the same category kinda
it's kind of lazy a little bit right i
don't mind it yeah who doesn't like that
am i right what about your favorite yeah
leslie is that what we're high fighting
for is this please give me two chicks
kissing every [ __ ] time that actually
gets my dick a little soft because i
can't put myself in that situation you
know really
are you liking them i force myself into
it
so you can't put yourself as one of the
women
you can't put yourself in that yeah that
oh my god
that's relatable use your imagination
yeah i can relate to that do you think
you would enjoy pasadena porn no there
was a category too close to home am i
right there's way too many pasadena porn
videos dude i'm so sick of it it's my
channel guys check out my my channel my
porn channel passing into old town is it
called old town boys old town boys and
it's just boys kissing each other yeah
in different landmarks in pasadena
here's us kissing at city hall
here we are at pcc
passing our ice skating rink
the intro is just like they call me john
mcmurray
there it goes maybe
let's kiss
that's going on the [ __ ] wall yeah
big b we gotta put some big beads is
that what i'm painting yeah you're
painting you're painting you already
signed up for it yeah okay all right
you're paying that you're really gonna
pay mcb that's cool man thanks
that's cool you man
[Music]
you